can you define a dramatist versus a
storyteller
sure uh a storyteller is just
making up a story and
any kind of story whether you're making
up a little five minute
story for your kid to go to sleep with
or you're
coming up with uh lord of the rings or
game of thrones yeah like
[Music]
high-end complex storytelling
huge and to succeed as a script writer
you need storytelling skills as big as
you can get them
the craft of the dramatist is connected
to storytelling but distinct from it
also because the craft of the dramatist
is how you dramatize a story
to adapt it for theatrical presentation
so it had you have to make your story so
that actors can perform it
on film on tv on stage and
that it grips the audience so the
audience is on the edge of their seat
wondering what comes next
you're making the material compelling
and conformable
performable so
the craft of the dramatist is
ancient uh
the first person who really chimed in on
it
that we know of was aristotle
he was not a playwright but each year
athens had a religious theater festival
in which a topic was assigned
to the playwrights of athens so
aristotle would over a couple day period
see
25 different versions of uh euripides
not you that was a playwright of um
well what's i'm blanking on the name of
the
play um oedipus so
uh he was able to compare and contrast
all these different playwrights takes on
the edible myth
and he found that some of them put the
audience to sleep and some of them
really gripped the audience
and he's like well what is it about
those dramas that grip an audience is
there anything
common among them and he found that they
tended to have a good strong dilemma
building to a crisis forcing decision
action in the face of crisis
with with a resolution of the dilemma by
the protagonist
and uh a danumo the upshot the epilogue
uh these were things that aristotle
noticed
tended to be common to those dramas that
gripped an audience and then
throughout the years there were french
classicists who
did amazing work and
shakespeare and and you know just
playwrights in general
and the science has continued to evolve
um there was a a new set of tools were
created
by this um script this broadway script
dr william thompson price
uh that he put out in his book 1908 and
he was teaching to his students
and he created these tools
because he found
that
most of the scripts that were submitted
for broadway productions that he was
working with the broadway producers on
missed the mark in some way a high
degree of them and that's still true
today that
90 to 95 of all scripts submitted
are do not work at all
they're horrible rejected unreadable
and the studio readers say don't kid
yourself it's 98
so what price did was he said these
people
are not landing in the ballpark very
often and
they're not stupid and they're good
storytellers they don't have enough
craft as a dramatist
and price was trained as a lawyer that
was his first
profession and
being trained in the logic of
argumentation
the ability to state a complete court
case
as a and b therefore c
and that is a rigorous process and if
you
present the logic of a court case
in the proper way then it's irrefutable
you prove your case by a and b therefore
c and your client wins
so he said there ought to be a way to
state the complete action of a script
with that level of simplicity and
clarity
and he by by
adapting the proposition of logic
to drama he created this tool because a
proposition is a
and b therefore c you're proposing that
this is true and this is true therefore
this is true
and he worked on it
for a long time he never ceased to be
dissatisfied with it but he
created it and advanced it and was able
to help their students
his students plays work 24 of his 28
students
had hits on broadway um
[Music]
but he was constantly trying to
synthesize it better
but it definitely worked and um
there was another playwriting teacher
who i found out later was
who taught price's technique of the
proposition
after price died in 1920 uh
prices student wrote a book in 1928
which is what those two books i read for
three years
and then this other playwriting teacher
wrote a book
in 1950 but he'd been teaching price's
proposition
and he advanced it even further
and what this teacher
said was um
trying to remember the exact wording can
i read it to you from my book it's i
have it right here if that's helpful oh
you do okay
i know it by memory but i'm not dredging
up all of it
this is my book writing a great movie uh
key tools for successful screenwriting
so let me read you actually a quote by
price about the proposition he's writing
in
1912. one main proposition is the
essence of unity
it is unity and unity can be procured in
no other way
it is impossible that two main ideas
exist in the same play
the house will be divided against itself
two bodies cannot occupy
the same space at the same time the play
itself
that which is developed from the one
idea is about many things
but the discerning eye of the author
should penetrate to the heart of things
true dramatic instinct which is largely
the product of training
usually does this with unerring
promptness for that one idea is
naturally the largest idea
a proposition involves the whole play it
must have a certain magnitude and the
play must be commensurate with it
it suggests action for the last clause
reply requires that a problem be worked
out
doubt is expressed the facts are given
opposition is encountered
so that's price talking about it and
then here is bernard grobanier in his
book playwriting he says
eventually price was able to formulate
his law of plot the proposition
which we are quite willing to agree is
the one significant contribution to the
science of playwriting since aristotle's
poetics
this was the judgment of many of his
students among whom were the most
successful american dramatists of their
generation
it is a large remark but as we say we do
not dispute it
even though price's very name seems
unknown to the public or to the scholars
these days
if we ourselves were asked to whom we
were indebted for the basis of our ideas
about playwriting
we should have to answer aristotle and
price price
really brought something entirely new to
the craft of the dramatist to the craft
of
making a story work dramatically for a
presentation
to an audience in such a way that it
grips the audience
and it's it's a
it's a complete craft in its own
and it's just
entirely distinct from storytelling from
one point of view
and yet completely married to it
because your dramatizing story
it's one of the things that i an analogy
that i recently stumbled onto
because what i'm teaching is seven
powerful tools
and we spend two years learning them in
this training program so we'll spend
months on each one and you have to
acquire expert facility with each tool
and then you gradually synthesize them
together into one unified
expertise and i compare it to
learning how to juggle while you're
riding on a unicycle
on a tightrope you have to learn each of
those skills separately
and then synthesize them together into a
fluid capability
so it's just a
set of skills that you get better and
better at
and you have to keep improving your
storytelling
because if your story ideas are weak it
doesn't matter how much craft you have
as a dramatist if your stories lack
magnitude then
it's not going to help much
and that was a point echoed by uh
ted elliott or terry roccio they wrote
uh pirates of the caribbean and a whole
bunch of other stuff
they said one of the most central
problems we
see in scriptwriters trying to succeed
is that their
core idea is poor
and that's so true
people put all this energy into
trying to turn a weak idea into a
stage-worthy script
and it's it's so central to it
uh i had dinner with a showrunner of a
top um network
uh tv series
and she was saying that
she sees so much bad writing that
will not work for their show and she
can't
show it to their to the star because he
won't
do it and she said that there's
that the writing itself is often so poor
that you have to like
decipher it to get out what they're
trying to say and when you finally
get down to the kernel of the idea it
sucks
too it's like there's no there there
there's all this stuff
built around something that doesn't work
in the first place
so storytelling is hugely important
and the craft of the dramatist is hugely
important
you can't succeed as a scriptwriter
without both of them
dialed to 11.
you